le centre culturel le plus vaste du
monde est en ce moment édifié ici ici
c'est à paris le plateau beaubourg à
deux pas de l'hôtel de ville près de la
cathédrale notre dame de paris à
quelques minutes à vol d'oiseau du
palais du louvre
c'est actuellement un des plus vastes et
des plus actifs chantiers parisiens
les fondations sont terminées d'édifices
sarr du sol
ce centre culturel en cours
d'édification et déjà connu sous le nom
de centre beaubourg près de la vieille
église st mary ce sera une immense
construction de verre et de métal une
conception novatrice qu'on doit à
l'architecte italien et anglais
renzo piano et jian franco franchini et
richard adjei
pour le secrétariat d'état à la culture
destinées duquel préside monsieur michel
guy le centre beaubourg comptera parmi
les réalisations les plus notables de
l'époque encore en chantier
c'est déjà un succès en fait vous savez
que c'est une initiative du proviseur
bros pidoux que le président giscard
d'estaing a souhaité poursuivre le plan
tel qu'il avait été prévu c'est pas
seulement un succès pour le secrétariat
d'état à la culture
en revanche c'est je crois un élément
très important dans notre politique de
création et de diffusion
parce qu'aussi bien je souhaite que
beaubourg fonctionne comme une sorte de
double entonnoir ouvert sur les
activités internationales et diffuser
largement dans toute la france et à
linverse je souhaite que cet entonnoir
fonctionne comme dans l'autre sens comme
en quelque sorte une espèce de centrales
de la décentralisation
c'est à dire récupère et montre les
activités des plus intéressantes de la
france et les diffuse largement à
l'étranger
on est impressionné par l'ampleur
exceptionnelle des trappes
quelles seront donc les dimensions de
cet ensemble culturel véritablement
monument dans son salon que la
profondeur des niveaux et de 60 mètres
environ y compris les str quand
verrons-nous beaubourg terminé en 1976
toutes les dispositions sont prises pour
que nous atteignons ce résultat pour
rappeler que tu es un concours
international lancé en 1970 jugez en 971
les travaux commencés dublin 73 le nous
sommes presque maintenant niveau 0 vont
être jugés d'après l'espace du chantier
est maintenant eh bien nous montons
bâtiment est très rapidement vous allez
le voir se dessiner dans le ciel
vous avez peut être été surpris mais sur
le chantier le port du casque est
obligatoire pour tout le monde parmi
toutes les activités du futur centre
d'obo les arts plastiques occuperont une
place très important et c'est à monsieur
pontus hulten qu'a été confiée ce
secteur
je suis là oui vous allez donc donné à
ces centres français je caractère
international que nous lui ce que ton
oui mais on va s'occuper de paris
d'autres villes en france aussi beaucoup
certainement du quartier présent ça sera
internationales nationales paris est le
cas je voulais aussi faire une animation
du quartier important est ce que vous
avez déjà des échos de la réputation du
futur beaubourg l'étranger on attend
vous savez que les bourses et là on a
quand même la chose la plus importante
qui se passe dans le monde du musée le
centre culturel au monde
c'est la chose qu'on discute partout on
veut dire donc le dans le monde entier
on en parle
ah oui qu'ils s'agissent des arts
plastiques se disent qu'une cinématique
s'agisse de la création industrielle
delà de la forme utile qu'il s'agisse de
la lutte et à de certaines formes de
théâtre qu'il s'agisse de la littérature
qui series du livre nous nous avons donc
là tout un ensemble avec un certain
nombre de surfaces qui peuvent être
aménagées avec des productions à
certaines ils resteront certainement
traditionnelles d'autres à inventer de
taille de dimension d'imagination
différentes et que nous cherchons à la
fois produire et aussi à atelier c'est à
dire que faudra pas nous attarder sur
l'ibère mais ça en même temps ouvert à
d'autres initiatives extérieures
une fois les travaux terminés l'église
médiévale saint merri surplombera le
département musical le plus moderne du
monde
jamais depuis sa mairie qu'il se situe
ici sera implanté en infrastructures
sous le niveau du sol les surfaces
réservées à l'institut de recherche et
de coordination anticipe donc dire qu'à
cannes c'est un institut pourra
s'attaquer à tous les problèmes de
musique contemporaine que les musiciens
et compositeurs ne veut pas résoudre
tout seul sur un endroit où nous pouvons
travailler ensemble et compositeur des
affluents si les scientifiques comme par
exemple les acousticiens ou des gens qui
s'intéressent à la passion aux enfants
dans la musique à la perception est
aussi ou pourra venir le public
spectateurs de toute l'expérience au
losc et des réserves ou les a eus écouté
dsk mais c'est vraiment un sens et des
pieds autour de lui il ya plusieurs
compositeurs comme luciano bref login
pour globe car gerald p les textes crade
et partie la terre le futur centre
beaubourg abritera également une vaste
bibliothèque publique organisée selon
les principes les plus fonctionnels
grandes caractéristiques de la
vidéothèque sur ce plan c'est qu'elle
sera en cycle politique abordera
absolument tous les sujets aussi bien
les sens exact que naît des sciences
dites humaines
ce sera une approche de tout le tout
domaine du savoir contemporain une
section sera consacré à l'un dans la
totalité de ses applications visuelles
nous voudrions chez nous montrer que
tout ce qui fait la qualité de la vie ou
vidéos même la culture mais pas
seulement de pure délectation comme chez
nos amis du département des arts
plastiques ou de la boue de la musique
mais que ça correspond à des besoins
pour le grand nombre et des besoins
je voudrais pas se dire organique que la
culture est quelque chose de très très
vaste et pas et pas fragmenté dits
spécialisés
disons que ça va
en gros du paquet de cigarettes la
machine outil oui et ou du bouton de
porte à porte à l'urbanisme
notre but de réunir en un seul une somme
documentation à double instrument doubs
par un instrument de recherche qui
permettra enfin aux chercheurs d'avoir
leur disposition tout ce qui leur est
nécessaire c'est à dire livre catalogue
d'exposition photos sur un instrument
aussi de communication et d'information
permettant aux artistes d'entrer en
contact avec tous ceux qui s'intéressent
à la rame en fait c'est surtout un
élément capital dans une politique qui
comporte comme vous pouvez l'imaginer
une sauvegarde assez vétilleuse du
patrimoine et d'autre part une aide très
active à la création